we begin with those new developments
today in that story we've been following
now for well over
a week a nationwide search it's now over
35-year-old samantha moreno-rodriguez
is now in police custody she was wanted
in connection to the death of her
seven-year-old son
liam hosted remember he was that little
boy found dead in mountain springs a
couple of weeks ago
bianca holman is live now in the
newsroom with details
from this morning hi bianca good
afternoon alex well police
they've been working around the clock
since liam was
found to try to again figure this all
out so it was around 8 30 this morning
that 8 news now
was notified that 35 year old samantha
moreno rodriguez
was located in colorado she's booked in
the denver downtown detention center so
this is what else that we
have learned so police they were able to
help
find out who the child was they shared
pictures throughout numerous states
a family member recognized the boy and
contacted san jose police
police determined the timeline liam and
his mother left san jose on may 24th
then on may 26 they were in laguna beach
area and also in victorville that
afternoon
liam's body was discovered may 28 in
mountain springs
the next day moreno rodriguez's car was
seen traveling on i-70
near grand junction police say she was
last seen on may 31
checking herself into this denver
comfort inn
a guest at a hotel says he was shocked
to see that arrest
i hope she gets what she deserves
because you know children's are innocent
you know that i mean you know it's not
the father came into this world you know
what i'm saying
but you know i hope she gets what she
deserves this has been an emotional
last 10 days for myself all the
investigators that have been working on
it
and we're just glad we're able to get
some closure for liam
and then hold the person responsible for
this crime accountable
now metro was able to confirm liam's
identity through an article of clothing
metro will has also scheduled a news
conference at 2 p.m this afternoon we're
going to take it live on air
and online bianca holman in the newsroom
back to you
a lot of new developments in that case
all right bianca thanks for following
that